all right here's a question to you guys
then because i don't i don't know if i'm
like just
getting old or is if if this is just
like it's just
just like boomer talk but do you feel
like do you feel like the golden age of
the internet has passed or has there
even been a golden age of the internet
i don't know i think the wild wild west
is gone yeah yeah definitely like right
if if i were to say
i don't know because like golden age of
something is such a [ __ ] secret
defines the goal it's so subjective yeah
the best period
but like this period based on what like
you're right i mean i mean it's
subjective
yeah right it's like just like basically
based on like your personal experience
with it or like best like objectively or
like best based on
something or other like because i can
argue that like okay
like my personal golden age of the
internet would be now because
it's easy to use yeah it's easy to use
like you know you can get
any information with anything and
everything is so conveniently laid out
but
best experience in terms of like my
overall enjoyment
of it would be like the mid-2000s
because that was like the golden age of
like new grounds and like flash games
and like that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] fun
and
none of that exists anymore i mean now
when i download something
i'm i'm like 99 percent sure it's not a
virus whereas
back then it was the opposite ratio yeah
well just everything virus but i really
want that cool mouse though that
popped up like really cool with the
sprinkles
i want to turn my cursor into like a
little cat i think i want
nine toolbars i remember the horror when
my
my mom showed me her laptop and i
thought i [ __ ] one of our pieces
she had like four internet explorer i
like [ __ ] toolbars and i'm like oh
god
yeah you know like at the time like i
hated it but you know the the
reminiscent like times of like going on
to my mom's pc and having to
swim through all the pop-ups just to get
to where i needed to go to it was like
i hated it at the time but now i look
back and it's like oh yes
internet do used to be like that because
i feel like everything now is
you know it's it's it's everything is
more formulaic more clean
yeah i'd say everything everything has
been like optimized yeah as we were
saying every it's like the internet has
definitely been optimized
um and you know it's that's why i bring
up the argument of like was it better
when it was like
had its charms when you feel like you
were discovering something new and it
was
it felt fresh you know or now that
everything's
formulaic everything's laid out
everything's clean yeah
that it's just less fun i mean like you
know the whole
like as i was saying earlier like the
whole like mystery of like discovering a
new anime
right like back then in like the mid
2000s was like it was [ __ ] great
because it was like going into a gold
mine that hadn't been discovered yet
yeah
right and like you know it was the whole
thing but at the same time it was a
double-edged sword right it was like
do i dare click on this anime to try and
discover it
with the risk of possibly getting i
don't know like seven trojan horses
coming into my house you know like
it's like do i take the risk it's like
oh well west here we go right
but nowadays it's like if i click on the
link like i'm fairly certain
i'm going to get something and it's
probably going to be something i've
already heard of right exactly the
entire mystery of it is gone like
oh my god the [ __ ] the amount of time
i spend on like new grounds for example
just going through just the most
shittiest of cartoons and flash games
to find that one game or cartoon where
it's just like i'll never [ __ ] dude
remember
do you remember the first time you
discovered like the [ __ ] stick figure
fights on new grounds
and it was just like the best [ __ ] ever
you're like i don't need top 10 anime
fights dude i have like xiao zhao
whatever the [ __ ] you scored
the moment i discovered like the
ultimate showdown of ultimate destiny oh
my god
like that [ __ ] when i when i found that
i was like this is peak internet like
nothing nothing will top this no movie
or experience will ever top this
that was the the song right yeah yeah
yeah this is the ultimate showdown yeah
that's the guy
the harry potter puppets yeah yeah yeah
same guy when i first discovered that i
was like dude
this this is my entertainment for the
next 20 years like i will never get
bored of this